tout part d'un article du wall street
journal affirmant que donald trump a
ordonné au pentagone de réduire à 25
mille le nombre de militaires présents
en allemagne
un article qui suscite l'inquiétude
outre rhin d'autant que la maison
blanche et le pentagone se refuse à
confirmer ou infirmer cette information
le ministre allemand des affaires
étrangères s'il assure que cette
présence militaire sert les deux parties
avoue que les relations ne sont pas au
beau fixe
nous apprécions la coopération avec les
forces armées américaines qui a grandi
au long des décennies
elle est dans l'intérêt de nos deux pays
nous sommes deux proches partenaires au
sein de l'alliance transatlantique
mais c'est compliqué il faut dire que
cet article survient dans un contexte de
tensions entre le gouvernement américain
et ses alliés européens au sein de
l'otan washington estime notamment que
berlin ne dépense pas assez pour sa
propre défense
actuellement quelques trente quatre
mille cinq cents soldats vivent avec
leurs familles sur une des 21 une base
militaire américaine en allemagne le
départ de 9500 militaire équivaudrait à
réduire significativement l'engagement
américain dans la défense européenne
dans le cadre de l'otan une décision
dangereuse estime dans un tweet un
ancien chef des forces terrestres
américaines en europe comme j'ai été
fortement impliqué dans les deux
dernières réductions structurelles de
l'armée de terre américaine en europe je
peux maintenant le dire publiquement
c'est dangereux ça démontre un manque de
vision et ça va se heurter au refus du
congrès et c'est un cadeau fait à la
russie qui va fragiliser nos alliances
mais peut-être aussi en créer de
nouvelles
dès le lendemain de la publication de
l'article le premier ministre polonais a
déclaré espérer qu'une partie des
soldats américains retiraient
d'allemagne seront installés en pologne
[Musique]